Mr Beast will be one of the most
financially successful entrepreneurs of
this generation he's got Gary Bayer's
talent in understanding context he has
Mark Brett's talent in understanding
production he has uncanny Drive of
winning the game not doing it for the
money he really really really
understands how to entertain he's very
thoughtful about Partnerships he knows
that if he makes great stuff that people
like to consume everything will be okay
here's another one he patient in a world
where a lot of people took their money
and bought Lamborghinis and houses he
stayed in South Carolina and he put all
the money into his next video so he
could spend a million dollars on it